if you've had your fill of star wars
battlefront and you're still looking for
more adventures in the Star Wars
universe then PlayStation Network has
you covered 3 playstation 2 Star Wars
games are now available for individual
purchase on PSN including Star Wars
racer revenge star wars jedi starfighter
and Star Wars bounty hunter all three of
these games have been up rendered to
1080p and have been updated to include
trophies share play remote play and
activity feeds bounty hunter lets you
take on the role of Jango Fett as you
travel the galaxy taking down all sorts
of galactic scum racer revenge puts you
behind the controls of a pod racer and
jedi starfighter lets you pilot famous
ships from the Star Wars universe you
can also pick up bounty hunter and raise
her revenge on ps3 and on either
platform each of these games will cost
you ten bucks hard time believing that
any of these games have aged
particularly well but if you want to
strap on Jango Fett's jet pack or take a
pottery surfer spin more power to you